-Welcome to the show. -Thank you.
-I'm so happy to have you on. I'm a big fan.
-Thank you. -You look great.
Am I saying your name correct?
Is it Camille Cottin? [cotton]
-Again? No, I'm kidding.
-Camille Cottin in America. -Yeah, yeah. It's perfect.
Yeah, it twists. It's great. Yeah.
-In France -- -It's flat.
It's like Camille Coh-tawn. So I prefer the way you said it.
-Ooh. Really, I thought that was beautiful what you said.
-Oh, yeah? -Camille Coh-tawn.
-Flat. Yeah, that's it.
-I almost want to whisper your name.
-Again? -Camille Coh-tawn.
-Yes. Yes, Jimmy, yes.
Jimmy Fal-ohn. -Ooh, I like that a lot.
[ Audience oohs ]
That's got a good ring to it.
You have a lot of fans here
because of the show "Call My Agent."
It's a French show that just kind of exploded in the U.S.
when it came to Netflix,
and they just announced you're doing another season.
-Are we? -Yeah. Yeah.
Just now. I just heard right before the show.
Congratulations. -Well, thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ] Thanks. Cool.
-How does it feel, though, when you find out
that people are loving it over here.
Is it fun?
-Well, I'm just starting to realize it, I have to say.
-Oh, really? -Yeah, well, being invited
by you, it's like -- Oh, yeah, this is serious.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-But it's very recent. Yeah. We didn't know.
We wrapped, and then there was the pandemic.
And then suddenly it's like, "America loves you!"
And you're like, "What?" I mean, America --
I just went to the supermarket this afternoon,
and they were really normal with me,
so I think it's still a niche.
-No. No. People know.
I mean, now you're doing these giant movies, too.
You're working with --
You were in "House of Gucci" with our pal Lady "Ga-ga."
We love her. Did you get to hang out with Lady Gaga?
-Oh, I wish I could, but she was really concentrating.
So she was into her character.
-You're supposed to be enemies in the movie.
-Yeah. Yeah, I'm her rival.
I'm stealing her husband,
so obviously she doesn't really like me.
-Yeah. She has a point. -She has a point.
But I have to say
that she's really not like her character in life.
So she was really concentrated, and then suddenly
she came between two takes and she said,
"You're a beautiful woman. You're a lovely actress.
And at the end of the movie, we'll be friends. Now hush!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- We love you, Gaga. Exactly right.
"At the end of the movie, we'll be friends," yeah.
-Yeah, she was nice.
-You've been performing since you were a child.
And you actually -- Your mom started a theater club?
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-What was it like working for your mom?
-Right. So, yeah. She created a theater club.
She had never acted, but she decided she would do this.
And then she decided that she would create this --
It's a bit like "Troy," the movie with Brad Pitt.
-Yes. -So it's a French play.
And I was given the part of Helene,
the most beautiful woman of the world.
It's obviously it's because my mom was giving the parts.
-Casting, yeah. She's like, "I know who
the most beautiful girl is. My daughter!"
-"Yeah, I got the part!"
And then, yeah, it was just incredible
because the most handsome guy of the school
just went to the theater club,
which is unusual because normally you get the geek guys.
-Yeah. Of course. The jock or...
-Yeah, yeah, not the cool guys.
And he was to be my lover in the play.
So I was, like, "Well, thank you, Mommy.
My dream is coming true."
-Best mom ever!
-But until then, it was all great.
And then we had to perform,
and he quit, like, I don't know, a week before.
So she said, "Now we'll never find somebody to do it.
So I'll do it."
[ Laughter ]
-Mom? -Mom.
Mom was on stage with me.
-So Mom stepped in for him? -Yeah.
And she was like, "My Princess, come and give me a kiss."
And it was like...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I love that. That's a pro right there.
That's a pro move right there, Mom. Good job.
Let's talk about "Killing Eve."
It's the fourth and the final season.
-Yes. -And what -- Can you --
Can you set up what's happening with your character?
-Oh, Helene. She's a villain. She's a true villain.
-Yes. -Vill-Helene. Yeah.
And what am I allowed to say? I don't know.
-I don't really know, either, because you're not really
allowed to spoil -- -No, not really.
-No. So, she's a villain.
-Yeah. She's a villain.
-That's all you can say.
-She's a very, very villain villain.
-Wow. A double villain? -No.
Yeah, double villain. -That's a spoiler. Okay.
-No. I can say she's a mom. -Yeah.
-And I thought it was quite funny
to be a villain and to be a mom. -Yeah.
-No, but I think it's -- Yeah, an interesting character.
-It's great. And congrats. It's another hit.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Camille Coh-tawn...
in "Killing Eve."
Take a look at this.
-Ow! -I feel rude you cooking me
dinner when I hardly know anything about you.
Tell me about yourself.
-I like holidays, dogs, long walks on the beach.
-And?
-And I want to bring down the 12.
I want to cut the head off the monster.
-That's wonderful. I like all of those things, too.
And guess what.
I also want to get the head of the monster.
-Really? -Amazing, isn't it,
when you find someone you can really connect with?
-That's right. That's how you do it.
Camille Cottin.
"Killing Eve" airs Sundays on BBC America and AMC Plus.